we are all ready for baseball in
chicago acuna freeman and ozuna
against the eight-year veteran
right-hander kyle hendricks
yeah 31-year-old dartmouth grad he's
going to carve you up with 86
miles an hour fastball he throws a
sinker a four-seamer
a curveball a change and he throws
everything to all four quadrants
of the zone tonight you should watch a
clinic acuna tearing it up here in the
first 15 games of the season
while weights is 1-0 pitch here it is
that's swung on the ground ball
into the shift backhanding it bodhi on
the shortstop side of the bag
goes over to first base and gets the out
and one down last year's
mvp in the national league freddie
freeman
freeman lifts off and that one's
well gone oh my goodness
out of the ballpark and into
wrigleyville
and it is one nothing in favor of the
braves on the homer by freddie freeman
goodness gracious that was launched that
cleared the bleachers out in right field
and just a perfect swing short tight to
the baseball
and just beat him to the spot had the
sound in the arc
falling to strike dudarno one for his
last 13 at the plate and darno swings
and sends the ball well he hit to left
and that one's gone a home run out of
darneau
and the braves who had done homework for
21 innings have now hit two in the top
of the first inning
and lead three to nothing change up 1-1
gets too much of the plate comes back a
little bit and darnold just
hammers it stays behind it nice and
controlled
two first inning home runs for the
braves hey ray adrianza ready to step in
hitting 294
3-2 pitch that swan hit it high into the
air out towards right field this might
have a shot
back of the wall as hayward kiss this
thing goodbye
another home run for the braves and it's
four to nothing
the braves have hid not one not two but
three bombs here in the first inning
no definitely didn't get all of it is
this ball's hit very high
to straight right field hayward goes
back and he's at the wall
in plenty of time but the wind blowing
out
as we said not blowing out real hard but
definitely
helping the ball carry a little bit and
hayward gets to the ivy
hendricks has been very good for a long
time and what we're seeing tonight
not typically at all when you get out of
hendricks that one's hit hard out
towards center field
this one's got a shot back there at the
wall is half he leaps
and this thing is gone four home runs
for the braves in the first inning
and it's six nothing atlanta wow
first hit for herrera and braves uni
and he goes to straight away center
field we got ourselves a firework show
on the north side of chicago
four home runs in one long flight ball
to the track 23 year old right hander
bryce wilson who's making his first big
league start
in quite a while you got to go back to
game four of last year's nlcs
two down for anthony rizzo fires rizzo
drives one in the air to right field
it's deep down the line acuna back at
the wall
gone rizzo with a home run to right
and the cubs get on the board number two
for anthony
and he was choking up ron with that
two-strike approach and he still
hammered one out of here
well you just you know you when you're
big and strong as
as anthony is you put the barrel on the
baseball
and you can hit it out of the ballpark
watch him pull his hands in right here
knee down head down the conference on
the mound after the base on balls and
hobby baes has the opportunity now for
chicago
shot to third base for riley who's up
with it throw to first miss
handle everybody safe better than that
bryant comes in to score
and it's a 6-2 atlanta lead the ball was
in the dirt freeman tried to backhand it
on the short hop it hit his glove he
didn't know where it was
it bounced behind him hustling all the
way from second and
scoring is bryant going to third on the
play is peterson
rizzo leads off the cubs third against
bryce wilson
and he'll drive one in the air left
center field this ball is back toward
the wall that ball is going to be
gone home run anthony rizzo
his second of the game and the cubs take
another step
closer now it's six to three can you
hear the big fella start heating up
you can feel it in yesterday's ball game
he got three hits in the game and walked
and now today
a home run to straight right and a
little back door hook he hits out of the
ball park to left
two balls and no strikes on freeman golf
again to first base back in with a diva
cunha
kind of gingerly gets up tries to shake
the dirt out of his uh
his belt buckle it's like he knocked the
wind out of himself with that dive he's
taking a minute to get back
runners take their leads here comes the
1-0 a little pop fly
shallow right hayward comes in tagging
it third as acuna the catch by jason
acuna is going to try to score the
throat of the plate cut off by rizzo
they've got freeman hung up between
second and third bae is running him
toward rizzo who will run freeman
back and now he'll lob it to bios
and out at second base and that ends the
unit the run is
him but in between innings ronaldo cunha
as he went sliding across home plate
head first very slow to get up and joe
he will not return
now it's ozuna in an rbi spot with a
runner at second and nobody out
the two one pitch change up broken back
flare to left field that's going to get
out for a hit
freddy freeman is around third he's
going to score
that'll make it eight to three on the
rbi single
and a real soft one it was nice to see
from marcelo zuna
five run lead for atlanta now would
nobody out travis darno the batter he
has homered tonight
that's into the right field corner more
damage
jason hayward indicating that it bounded
up and perhaps hit a fan
he gets on it anyway as darno wheels
into second
and scoring all the way from first is
ozuna we'll take another look at that
again
and the ball was going into the stands
and a braves fan with bad hands didn't
catch it
and knocked it back into the field of
play they will take another look at this
as an official review as all boundary
calls are reviewable
top of the sixth frames up 9-3 and the
pitch
swung on hit in the air left center
field back goes
jack peterson that ball is gone grand
slam
home run for guillermo haradia
guillermo hero adia with the slam his
second homer of the night
13-3 atlanta on the bad end of a 13-4
game
yesterday 24 hours later
it's the braves flipping the script
atlanta took the opener five to two
yesterday the cubs had a 13-4 victory
and tonight
same score but atlanta walks away with
the win
and taking two out of three at wrigley
final score tonight
13-4 braves